the minister for energy clean growth and
climate change greg hans joins us in the
studio morning see you in the flesh
minister um
and i think you know where we're going
to start this morning four very very
senior individuals in number 10 have
left or about to leave with the greatest
respect just what the hell is going on
in number 10 at the moment
well
let's not forget that on monday the
prime minister when responding uh to the
sugree report update made clear that
there would be changes
at the top in number 10. resignations
have been made resignations have been
accepted these are all people who've
done fantastic service to the country
throughout the pandemic in almost all of
those cases and we should be thankful
for them for their service but the prime
minister was absolutely clear on monday
uh that there will be changes at the top
in number 10 and that is what he's
delivered what will three of the
resignations may well be a response to
sue graham you know moser who we'll talk
about in a second that has nothing to do
with that but in terms of the three that
you identify as a response to the sue
gray update why didn't the prime
minister wait for the metropolitan
police to conclude their investigation
well because he was clear on monday that
there would be changes to the operation
yeah obviously he was going to do those
immediately obviously he said he did say
to eb and i and i have to admit it's
it's been the mantra from government for
many weeks now wait for sue gray sue
gray provided an update then it was wait
for the metropolitan police
investigation
to conclude hasn't the prime minister in
accepting these resignations or perhaps
even pushing for them simply you know
drawn conclusions that he shouldn't have
done before the met had done their job
no i disagree with that this is about
the prime minister uh saying that there
were the sugray uh report update said
that there were
failings at the top at the top of the
operation uh this is the prime minister
taking charge is a wider issue than just
uh the sugray report it's actually
saying that we need changes at number 10
which is what the prime minister said he
would deliver on monday okay so who are
replacing the chief of staff then who's
replacing the chief of staff well i
understand that dan rosenfield is
carrying on until such a time as he is
replaced
we will see you know i would expect the
prime minister to appoint a very very
capable person
or capable people in those roles it is
after all a great honor
to work at number 10 and to serve your
country and i'd expect very capable
people to be in there so the only
problem with that analysis is that if
this was part of some carefully thought
out and constructed plan surely you
would have the names of those who would
be replacing them ready to go isn't the
simple fact of the matter that the prime
minister rushed out a couple of
resignations that were planned for next
week because menier and mirza marched
out the front gate number 10. well the
resignation of manila mirza is a little
bit different i accept that
she made clear her reasons for her
resignation the prime minister equally
clear that he disagreed with her but
nonetheless manir is somebody who's put
in an amazing service i know as a london
mp uh the incredible role she's played
for boris johnson both as mayor of
london now as prime minister
and we shouldn't leave without paying
tribute to the amazing work that she's
done um for the people of london the
people of the country over the past 15
years sure well let's let let's not
gloss over why um minera merza quit
number 10. there are suggesting that
there are plenty of other reasons rather
than those stated but let's just take a
quick look at the stated reasons if we
can bring up that graphic
uh she says this i believe it was wrong
for you to employ this week that
kierstarma was personally responsible
for allowing jimmy sabal to escape
justice there was no fair or reasonable
basis for that assertion she continues
you're a better man than many of your
detractors will ever understand which is
why it is so desperately sad that you
let yourself down by making a scurrilous
accusation against the leader of the
opposition and it's not even not just
manira mirza who feels that the prime
minister spoke out of turn uh in linking
jimmy savile to keir starmer here's what
the chancellor had to say uh on this
particular topic yesterday
with regard to their comments
know being being honest i wouldn't have
said it and i'm glad that the prime
minister clarified what he meant
so you've got manira murder resigning
over this the chancellor saying he
wouldn't have said it simon clark of
course saying that he believed it was an
entirely reasonable remark would you
have said it
uh look the prime minister was clear
yesterday in response to monira mirza's
resignation that he disagrees at the
basis of her resignation what she had to
say the prime minister was also clear on
wednesday that he was referring back to
the public apology
made by saquia starmer and i think it
was 2013 and it was all about a wider
thing about taking responsibility uh for
an organization for the faith you've
said in an organization would you have
said it in the way that the prime
minister did protected by parliamentary
privileges privilege at pmq's well look
the prime minister said that he
disagreed yesterday with the basis of
the resignation of what manila mirza had
to say and that that i think is the end
of the matter well it's not the end of
the matter because i can ask the
question for a third time would you have
said it
look i'm saying the prime minister
disagreed with what she had to say that
is the important thing here
these are all events that happened many
many years ago the time is now to move
on and look at what the country wants us
to focus on which is recovery from the
pandemic further vaccination roll out uh
move to net zero the energy transition i
get i get the impression i'm not going
to make much headway on that particular
question so let's do that which you ask
and move on to the measures which the
chancellor was announcing yesterday you
know measures which i'm sure plenty of
people will warmly welcome extra money
as we see the cost of uh living sore but
let's just look at a couple of the ways
in which the chancellor described the
council tax money and the energy at cap
money yesterday let's just have a quick
look at what he said yesterday he said
this
it's a flat rate a flat 200 pounds and a
flat 150 pounds that's obviously going
to mean more to families on lower
incomes or with lower energy bills so in
that sense it's a progressive measure
that will help those family more has
rishi soon act just redefined
progressive
no i sat next to him in the house
commons
when he made the announcement yesterday
uh as we know energy bills i'm the
energy minister are quite regressive uh
therefore the more that you can provide
for those uh on lower middle incomes the
better that is why we've also done
things
like the rise in the national living
wage from eight pounds 91 an hour to
nine pounds fifty an hour giving
somebody on the national living wage an
extra one thousand pounds in their pay
packet these council tax rises for those
living in bands a to d and also the
households on energy uh with the energy
bills that a 200 pound discount on their
energy bills all of these will give a
lot of help to those not just on low
incomes but also middle incomes who are
going to be hit by the rise in energy
bills that will come in from april but
it's just that whenever politicians have
used the term progressive in the past
particularly progressive taxation or so
on it's a measure which takes into
account the circumstances of the
individual affected this this pays no
attention certainly the 200 pounds
towards energy bills pays absolutely no
heat to the individual circumstances
does it well look the overall package so
things like the council tax
rebate for those living in bands a to d
properties there's also 144 million
pounds for local authorities um to deal
with people who for example are in low
income but have high energy bills these
are all very progressive measures as of
course as the national living wage
increase and the changes in the
universal credit taper rate all of these
will actually really help people on low
and middle incomes
again i'll just make the point it
doesn't strike me as particularly
progressive to be handing out to
everyone those who desperately need it
and those who perhaps do not desperately
need it 200 pounds but but more than
that why are we describing it as a
rebate when it is pretty clearly alone
okay it is a discount first of all
you've got to look at in terms of
whether the message whether the whole
set of measures are progressive you've
got to look at all of the measures that
were announced by the chancellor
yesterday and at the budget in november
we are describing the energy bill
change as a discount the council tax is
a rebate the council tax gets given to
200 pounds one-off will not be repaid uh
the 200 pounds on energy bills is a
discount because that will be repaid by
the bill pair but over a five-year
period and that's quite a long period of
time to be able to repay that the reason
for the five-year period as i understand
it is by that point you seem fairly
certain that that is when wholesale
prices energy prices may have returned
to normal no i'm not i'm not predicting
energy prices sure but what we are
saying about energy price has been
incredibly volatile of course of course
you know they're four to five times the
average over the last 25 years at the
moment but they're actually equally half
the peak so energy prices are very
volatile we're not doing a prediction
energy prices what we are saying is that
people need help now which is why we are
giving people the 200 pound discount
which will come in october but it's
certainly been mentioned by those in
government that 2024 is a point by which
you know wholesale the wholesale prices
market may well have just calmed down a
little bit that certainly there's been
something that's said so i'm wondering
with energy prices expected to remain at
high levels for a number of years is
this a one-off it can't be a one-off
cannon well we'll have to see what the
decisions of the future in relation uh
to energy you're not ruling it out
you're not suggesting that this is a
one-off payment and that's it there may
be future assistance it is my job to
make sure the country is prepared on all
things related to energy it's not my job
to make
if you like energy price forecasts for
the future energy prices have been
elevated for the last nine months or so
they've also been very volatile in that
time that is why we're bringing in that
support
right up front the nine billion pound
package of support announced by the
chancellor yesterday in response to
energy price rises and other price rises
coming in this year but just but just on
on the council tax rebates i mean the
times describes it as loopy and lopsided
the point that they make london boroughs
with huge property prices will receive
the same as properties in the midlands
and the north indeed that actually pay
hundreds more in council tax
again not progressive well that's why
we've got the 144 million pounds extra
for local authorities to look at those
cases where somebody is on low income
but has a high energy bill eg living in
a high value property that will be in
council tax bands
e and above and that's also why that
fund is there also for people who don't
pay council tax people on very low
incomes who don't pay council tax at all
that is why we have the 144 million
pound local authority fund why does the
prime minister seemingly not pay any
heed to the optics of what he is doing
at the moment i mean let's just reflect
on what happened yesterday the bank of
england told us that we're in for a
record slight in living standards that
you know the governor of the bank of
england himself and roughly bought in
excess of 500 grand a year tells us all
not to ask for big pay rises on that day
the prime minister to an event in
blackpool takes a private plane
well look i i can promise you the prime
minister travels by train a lot uh i see
him on the train he he
going by train is is like
prime minister loves training buses
taking the plane to australia
the prime minister's had a difficult
schedule this week don't forget you know
he's had responded to the sugray uh uh
update on monday he's been to the
ukraine on tuesday he should that is a
long distance 50 minutes off his journey
but he's flying
hold on but he's come back on wednesday
to answer prime minister's questions in
the house comments on thursday he's in
blackpool that is a difficult schedule
for anybody
and i know the prime minister and he is
somebody who instinctively loves public
transport that's what i saw when he was
mayor of london i was one of his mps in
london he is somebody who loves public
transport but has been a difficult you
would agree that's a difficult
challenging schedule this week for him
minister great to have you on the
program this morning thank you for
joining us